Welcome everyone.
Today we have such an important topic
talking about lymphatic diseases and
lymphedema for me personally
today is incredibly important.
I'm the chief medical officer at verily
and fairly is the branch of alphabet
that focuses on healthcare and
life science, but across alphabet,
our appreciation of both health
and disease continues to grow.
So I think all of you
for being here today,
the other piece is as a cardiologist and
having the ability to work with docs or
rocks and, and the crew you're going
to see today has been a real pleasure.
I think all of us will walk away with
more knowledge and more compassion.
So I'll introduce our guests and then
and then turn it over to them for a
conversation. One thing I will notice,
we will take questions at the end.
So please think along the way,
uh,
of your questions and we certainly welcome
them. So to my left, we have a doctor,
Stan,
Roxanne,
cardiologist to professor at Stanford and
you will learn and hear about his true
passion, uh, for the disease
we're talking about today.
We also have Kathy Bates who needs no
introduction to a academy award winning
actress,
a director and a philanthropist.
And I think her role in champion
lymphatic disease has been remarkable.
And we have bill rich CP who since 2011
has been the president and CEO of a
group called learn and learn has been
focusing on individuals who have lymphatic
disease and lymph edema.
I should also note that he spent 35 years
in place himself, so maybe he'll uh,
he'll provide some color there as well.
So thanks again.
I'll now turn it over to Stan to tell
us a little bit about what we're talking
about when we think about this,
this set of conditions, the
issue that we're going to talk about
is a very important part of the
circulation.
One that is commonly not recognized
because it's working in the background.
And the problem is that medical doctors
don't know much about it either.
They should, but they don't.
As I mentioned in 2007,
I did a study of the 110 medical schools
in North America to find out exactly
how much time is spent on the system.
And in a four year medical education
we learned about 15 minutes.
If you're lucky and go to a really
good medical school, 30 minutes.
I did bring something for show and tell,
uh,
just to show you how ludicrous that is.
This is a textbook on lymphedema
that we just re edited. Uh,
this is what a well trained
clinician should know.
It's a thousand pages. There's no
way you can cover this in 15 minutes.
We can't cover it in five minutes,
which is what I've been allotted.
But let me give you just a little bit of
background. Uh, so the lymphatic system,
I'm going to use the
metaphor of a brick wall.
If I ask all of you to imagine
a brick wall and then a mat,
and then describe to me
what you are looking at.
You're likely to tell me something about
rectangular shaped objects that are
overlapping, stacked on one
another, a maroon color.
And I bet almost nobody will tell me about
the white mortar that sits around the
bricks. And yet we know without the
mortar you don't have a brick wall,
you have a pile of bricks.
The white mortar in the body
is the lymphatic system.
It is the part of the circulation that
ensures that the local pond in which
every cell operates,
has the right constituency,
has the right volume,
and is able to support the health of
those cells and the lymphatic circulation
passes through lymph nodes and the lymph
nodes help all parts of the body to
communicate to the immune
system when there is a threat,
whether it is a toxin or a bacteria
or a virus or anything that the immune
system needs to respond to.
So without this vital system,
without the mortar,
everything will collapse.
The disease that we're talking about
today, the common lymphatic disease,
not the only one,
but the most common one is lymphedema,
which is basically when the wall collapses
in a part of the body because that
part of the body is not functioning
with normal lymphatic constituency.
And basically we understand a lot
about why that condition arises.
We understand who's at risk for it and
we have treatments for it, but the,
the obstacle that we face is that medical
practitioners are simply not aware.
Let me tell you just a few of the
contexts in which we see lymphedema.
We talk about secondary
and primary lymph edema.
Secondary lymphedema
means that you're born,
your lymphatic system is normal,
everything is operating well and something
injures the system and you develop
this swelling problem and this immune
malfunction in a part of your body that is
secondary lymphedema.
And the most common cause in the United
States is being treated for cancer.
Because when doctors treat cancer,
they remove lymph nodes from the body,
they irradiate lymph nodes and they
damage the system in a way that renders it
unable to function properly.
In the world at large,
and we're talking about 90 million
people, it is filariasis, which is a,
an infectious problem.
It's a parasite that attacks the lymph
nodes and destroys them and causes a very
severe form of lymphoma called
elephantiasis. Here in the United States,
probably five to 10 million
Americans have this problem.
Difficult to know because doctors aren't
writing the diagnosis down and if they
don't enumerate it,
we can't enumerate it.
But by projection and
by oblique references,
we think that that's a fairly
valid number. In that fiber.
10 million cases,
there are perhaps 2% of those who are
born with genetic causes of lymphedema.
That is the lymphatic system
is malformed or it is,
it is functionally incompetent because
of the genetic makeup of the individual.
Now, don't mistake inborn
problems with congenital.
Some lymphedema that is
primary is congenital,
but some appears in the teenage years.
Some appears in young adulthood and many
cases appear after the age of 35 even
though the defect is present in the
blueprint of the body from birth.
So those are the broad categories,
um, that we're talking about.
Now,
just to show you how ludicrous the problem
is that we face in medical education
and medical practice.
I recently saw a patient,
a woman who has pretty severe lymph edema,
swelling and deformity of her limbs,
both lower extremities,
both legs. She was treated for colon
cancer. She had lymph nodes removed,
she had radiation therapy
and for approximately a
year and a half during which
time her legs were getting
progressively more enlarged.
None of the doctors would acknowledge
that she had a problem and nobody
certainly gave it a name.
Eventually through back channels and
talking to people and other individuals in
the community, she learned
the name lymphedema. She
went to her doctor and said,
I think I know what this is. This is
lymphedema. The doctor said, oh no.
That only happens in the arms
to breast cancer patients.
It doesn't happen in the legs.
Preposterous.
Not even in that 15 minutes did this
physician learn that this can happen
anywhere in the body because the
lymphatic circulation is everywhere.
Now Jessica said that she's a
cardiologist. I'm a cardiologist.
I got interested in this field because
I'm interested in understanding how the
circulation maintains its integrity
and when I went through my training,
I can readily admit I didn't know
anything about lymphedema until I chose to
embrace the lymphatic circulation as an
entity for research and clinical care,
but I think it's vital. It is vital, not
only that cardiologists know about it,
but basically every physician who
purports to take care of patients.
So we're hoping that those of you in the
room today and those that are watching
this afterwards, we'll take a
profound interest in this problem,
which is global and it,
the impact on the patients'
lives is extraordinary.
It's not generally a life threatening
condition. It does not shorten life,
but it certainly impacts the way in
which those individuals could live their
lives. So this is something we need
to embrace. We need to acknowledge,
we need to treat it
and eventually we need to be able
to prevent it and reverse it.
So that's what I'll say.
Oh, thank you for that incredibly
impactful introduction.
I for one, will continue to be a champion
of the work that you all are doing.
Kathy,
you're here as a spokesperson for learning
the organization we talked about and
I think everyone here would really like
to hear about your journey and how,
how,
how you have found the condition and
what it's been like working with Lauren.
Uh, yes, I, I think I don't
need a microphone, but, um, um,
I,
six years ago I had a double mastectomy
and I knew what lymphedema was before I
had been diagnosed with breast cancer.
I was more afraid of lymph edema then
I was of living without my breasts.
Uh,
my mother had it.
I saw the effect it had on her left arm
when she had a radical back in the 70s.
Her arms swelled terribly.
Um,
I had a friend that I knew had
lymphedema in his left arm.
He,
um,
had had a melanoma underneath his
arm and they took a tissue from the,
the damaged part and reinjected,
you know, so he survived,
but his arm was extremely heavy.
Like would,
he had seen enough doctors in his life.
He decided so he wouldn't go for care.
And it terrified me,
um,
that I would get this condition sometimes.
We used to go driving in an RV
and driving was very hard for him.
His arm would swell terribly
and we'd stop and get fresh,
high ace bandages and,
but sometimes lymph would ooze out of
his fingers because he was so stubborn
about it. Anyway, I was
really concerned. Uh,
I thought maybe I would
have a predisposition to it
given my mother's history.
And I remember,
um,
on several occasions
really begging my surgeon,
please at the sentinel node is clear,
get out.
I don't want to have this, I
don't want to have it. And, um,
I had the surgery and when I was in the
hospital I was feeling strange little,
it was almost like an electrical storm.
And I don't know if this
is lymphedema coming on,
but it certainly felt strange to me. And,
uh, when I went in for my first checkup,
he told me he had taken 19 notes from
this arm and three from the other.
I am, uh, because of my career. Uh,
you've seen me in raged
Amin in several roles.
I think you should multiply my
reaction by about a hundred.
I went nuts and screaming,
yelling, crying. Uh, they,
people came in the room
to try to calm me down.
There was a social worker speaking
in that social worker voice.
Now we just take a breath and I think
I turned to her like the exorcist,
you know,
and I ran out of the building.
I left my niece and my best friend and
I ran out of the building in the middle
of July, standing near the Beverly Center.
It was so hot. I still had my drains in.
I was holding this pillow and when I
finally came to my senses, I thought,
I can't walk home. I, I don't want
to, you know, get any further damage.
So I was really,
really enraged.
And as he told my niece,
he said,
lymphedema would be a moot
point if she doesn't survive.
I don't want to malign my surgeon.
He's a good man.
His focus was on curing me of
cancer period. And in fact,
when I was having my fit in the room,
he kept saying,
I cured you a cancer. I cured.
You have cancer. I mean,
he believed that so passionately.
That was his goal.
And he felt that he had accomplished that.
And I,
I wouldn't be here today without him.
I have to acknowledge that.
So I was pretty angry for a long time.
And then through one of my other surgeons,
I got the name of Dr Emily Eicher and
I found out I could go have manual.
I did develop lymphedema in both arms and
they began to swell and I had pain and
heaviness and rashes and a heat.
And, uh, so anyway, I went to her very,
very angry person and she was lovely.
And she said,
that's all in the past. Lao, let's
begin your new life. She said,
I have a patient who was 105. If you
want to know about the stock market,
call her.
And she dresses in Chanel every day,
so the future is bright for you. So, uh,
then I became involved with Emily.
She has lymphedema in her right leg
and that's why she became involved in
specialized in,
in study of lymphatic lymphedema
and lymphatic disease.
So I began a program with
her going frequently and
then I was able to taper off.
Um,
and then Emily led me to bill for PC and,
um,
she said,
I'm doing this one walk in Venice
and I just don't know how to do this.
And I did that. Okay. I figured
she had ulterior motives.
Finally when I figured out
what was going on. And um,
bill and I met in New York and bill
gave me the numbers that Stan has just
described.
And then I got really pissed off and I
never have loaned my name to any group
such as this over the course of my career.
But I couldn't say no. I
was so enraged. And when I,
the more I learned about it and the more,
the fact that doctors don't know,
my goal was to raise awareness.
And that's why I love the name learn.
And I just, I thought, and I
went to school, Dan, you know,
when we went to Capitol Hill that
first year, I said, what's the deal?
Why can't we just go to Jama and say,
get on the horn, talk to these guys,
let them know what's going on,
have them know what to look out for.
And we tried that.
And you even wrote an article that got
turned down in a couple of hours and
under anyway.
So it seemed like Everest to me and uh,
that I would be going with APP oxygen all
alone. But then as I began the journey,
I was relieved to know that there are
actually people and have been people for
the last 15 years,
working diligently on research,
working on trying to raise awareness,
working on trying to reach physicians.
And today I'm relieved that
that we are making progress.
I left New York,
we went to a cocktail fundraiser,
a very wealthy couple,
a woman who's very involved in research,
my scoby Crosby.
And it was fascinating to meet with
her and doctor Diane who is doing a
replacement as you call it, re
reconstructions transfer. Right.
And a doctor, uh, uh, Shelly
Feldman, I learned so much from them.
Okay, so get this. So they had a
lovely dinner for us afterwards.
And I had my best friend with me
and she was seated next to a one.
I wasn't next to them and it
wasn't very well heeled group.
And she was talking to the lady and she
noticed that the lady wasn't eating her
dinner and just pushing her food
around and she seemed upset.
And Jennifer asked her, she said,
so why are you here? And whatever.
And the woman just said, oh
my God, now I know what I had.
I've had it for years. Right. And
Jennifer was, so she's very shy. Anyway,
so I said, where, where
does she have it? You know,
I wanted to know all the details for
our purposes, but she didn't ask.
And uh,
but I was astounded that someone who had
all the resources and the money to be
educated and to find the best
doctors had been living with this.
Uh, and the one other thing, I don't
want to take up too much time, but
the numbers that Stan told
me began to disappear.
You have to, excuse me if I get
a little emotional about this.
The numbers disappear.
And you know,
when you meet people one on one
and you listen to their story,
you begin to empathize with
what they have to deal with.
And what I learned was from these people,
I just met Rosalie today who has primary
lymph edema and has it throughout her
body for the last 30 years.
And rose wanted to be an Irish dancer.
It reminds me of Pearland Hines,
who was one of people who emailed us,
a young woman who suddenly at the age
of 20 her leg blew up the answer just
about to blossom.
And suddenly her career was over.
But instead of getting up,
and this is what I love about this,
is when you really get to know somebody,
you see what they're made of.
And after going through the
horror, the denial, the struggle,
she realized and she said,
um,
I realized that if I
continue to deny this,
that the legs of future
generations would be lost.
We have another woman, Karen
Bingham, up in Nova Scotia.
Her six of her siblings have it.
Her father had had huge,
huge legs and she didn't know what it was
until the internet came along and then
she began to realize other people
are out there who have this,
so she went on Facebook and she posted
a picture of one of her legs because she
figured, you know, a picture's
worth a thousand words,
and she heard from Facebook right away and
said, you have to take this down. It's,
it's,
it's undesirable to look at.
And in all fairness to Facebook,
they have a policy about nudity.
And so someone had complained that
here's this woman showing their nude leg.
I'm on Facebook,
but things then began to roll for her.
She posted this response on Facebook to
her friends and they got pissed off and
they talked to other people.
She developed a seminar for people up
in Nova Scotia. She got local publicity.
Then she got national publicity.
She and I have been DME.
She'd went to a gym.
A doctor told her,
just don't do anything for two years,
lying in bed, and she said, well,
this is not living. She did it,
but she said, this isn't living.
She went and learned how
to be a real estate agent.
Then she went to a gym
that was hard to find.
She finally found a guy who worked with
her and she does kickboxing now and she
is very vocal about what's going.
She's joined our group. Uh,
she's a wonderful
spokesperson for us. And, um,
there's one other young woman that I
want to, young girl really to talk about.
Emma Detlef son who's one of my
favorites that I've stayed in touch with.
And she actually came
with, with us to the, uh,
awards that we got in
Washington to stand up. Um,
she has it in her legs,
was born with it and uh,
she at right went to the
New York state legislature.
She appeared there and there was a
bill there that's still there, uh,
that was languishing
for research. And, uh,
after she appeared it was bipartisan
support and one of the, uh,
Congress people there said,
we have to help these children.
And um,
and then when I think she was about,
was it eight or was it the same
year? Right after that. She,
Bill has a wonderful a walk run on the,
over the Brooklyn Bridge,
which I'm going to get to one day.
We have ours in Venice and um,
she had, she was our, uh,
youth advocate, right. And uh,
she wrote a speech and have to tell you
she in those seven years because of the,
uh, cellulitis, which is an infection
that you can very easily, uh,
have with any kind of a nick or
cut, you don't know. I've had it,
I thought I had a very
mild case of lymph edema,
but Stan has explained to
me if you got lymphedema,
you got lymphedema and I had to go into
the hospital and was there for almost a
week and they sent in tropical disease
specialist and put me on some kind of
antibiotic that nearly killed me.
And um,
they just didn't get it.
Um,
but imagine being a child and in eight
years of your life you've been to the
hospital eight times with doctors who
still don't really get it or believe it.
She said something at
the end of her speech
that will stay with me forever.
She said,
if I can do something hard for me like
walk back and forth across the Brooklyn
Bridge,
maybe a smart scientist can do something
hard for them and find a cure for this
in my lifetime,
the people that I have met through
this program, their courage,
their struggle to live with
this has been so touching to me.
The doctors.
However,
I would like to encase
just one leg in concrete.
It sounds like I'm going
all Annie Wilkes on them,
but in my business,
imagination is the key.
You have to use your imagination
because only with that can you begin to
empathize. Now, I won't put
you through it today for today,
but as a as a thank you to me
for having been here today.
Tonight, when you go to bed,
just lie in bed, close your eyes,
settle,
breathe,
and imagine that your right leg,
your left leg is so swollen
that it will never go down.
It's like your, your leg is going to
be in jail for the rest of your life.
You're going to have to wear compression,
compression garments if you
can afford them. If they fit,
you're going to have to
buy two pairs of pants.
You're going to have to buy two pairs
of shoes. If fits in your right leg,
you're going to have a hell
of a hard time driving. Uh,
there are so many, just physical
problems alone. They can seem daunting.
It's psychologically debilitating,
it's emotionally debilitating.
I have talked to people who
have this who have been,
I use the word ostracized by doctors.
I think doctors are so turned off,
they just don't want him there.
There's a woman in Russia,
Tatiana,
who had it when she was in her twenties
and the doctor literally told her,
you should be glad you have all
your arms and legs get Outta here.
So that's what we're up against.
And that's what I've tried to do
is to educate physicians. You know,
if somebody who's notices I've got my
compression sleeve on and they'll say,
what is that? I'll say,
well how long have you are?
Cause I just want to take
every opportunity and you
just never know that you're
showing me. You were saying to me
when we went to physical therapy,
one of the physical therapists there
has it and she came out and talked to me
and you just never know where
you're going to meet people.
So I thank you all for being today.
I hope I haven't gone on too long,
but it's such a, you know,
just to finish up for me,
who spends a lot of time trying to
figure out how to be other people.
It's really nice, although I
wish I didn't have lived the day.
It's really nice to be able to be me and
to hopefully do some good in the world.
The thank you all so much for being here.
It means the world.
Take a moment.
I um,
I have to say your passion is so evident
and I can see why they call you all the
Dream Team.
And I do think this idea of empathy and
sympathy across the board is something
that we're all striving for.
And thank you so much
for sharing your story.
The other thing that's very clear
as I got to know bill recently,
I can see why you were immediately drawn
to learn and I think for all of us,
it'd be helpful to hear a little more
about your mission and I'm going to ask
you to share some of the sentiments
you were talking with me about earlier.
When we have a certain
entity like lymphedema,
whether we call it a condition
or a disease matters and
your insights there were
incredibly impactful. So thank you
again for being here. Yeah, yeah,
a real pleasure.
I get to follow Kathy Bates.
How's that Tara? What?
What's funny, I mean this team here,
I mean really a faded to be. I mean,
it lifted emo, lymphatic diseases
have been ignored for a long time. Uh,
when I first met Kathy, Dr Acres,
the window first put us together.
We met in New York and we talked for a
couple of hours and Kathy was listening
intently and at the end of
the conversation said both,
this is all fascinating bill.
I have to have to think about it.
I'm not sure if I'm ready to be a
spokesperson. This is all new to me,
but you know,
we'll follow up at a later date,
but I have to go right now because I have
a TV show I need to go to. And I said,
well, what TV show is that
you're doing? And she said, well,
Andy Cohen's watch what
happens. I did this. I said,
Andy lives upstairs from me.
And I ranted to Andy and the elevator
yesterday and I asked him if he would be
the very first member of learns
honorary board. And he said, sure,
belt whatever you want.
And Kathy stared at me and said,
that's the sign.
That's the side it was meant to be.
I learned spokesperson and
that's how it all began.
And kicked off a learned was established
20 years ago. This is in fact,
our 20th anniversary. Stan was
available. Doctor Roxon. Uh,
right from the very beginning of
it, uh, the way it all started, uh,
a woman dealt with what women and
families had dealt with for eons,
but not taking the next step. She had a
child, we had a primary lymphatic disease.
Doctors didn't know anything about it.
They didn't have any hope for it.
They didn't know how to treat it.
She decided that that wasn't acceptable
and began the process of creating this
organization that we then focus mainly
on the whole research issue because then
there was very little research.
So how do you get researchers into the
field to begin really looking at this
issue? By the time I come around,
which is six years ago, uh,
I come in and I'm interviewed for a
job that didn't give the name of the
organization or mentioned
the word lymphatics.
So when I got done and they
told me what this was about,
I actually turned the job down when it
was offered to me because I knew nothing
about lymphatics or lymphedema.
That was not my background.
I had a specialty and
developmental disabilities and
infectious diseases to some
degree from working in Kenya, et
Cetera. But this was unknown to me.
After turning that job down,
I went out and started talking to
people and talk to some of the most
sophisticated, wealthy as, uh,
most educated people. I knew.
None of them knew what I was talking
about until I described it and invariably
after I did describe it,
the response was my mother has
that she had breast cancer.
Her arms like this,
it has a name,
doctor's wife raising or like in the air
saying whatever you're talking about,
I've had it since I was a child. My
doctor says it's called drainage issues.
What became fascinating to me of
why it went back and took the job,
as I began to see the
marketing implications of what
was going on here, as as,
as Dr Roxanne and Cathy have said,
we estimate there could be
up to 10 million people in
the states alone that have
lymphedema.
I started putting the numbers together.
How many people in the United
States had multiple sclerosis?
500,000 how many of the AIDS,
300,000 perhaps a million or HIV positive.
How many have als? About 30,000 when
all was said and done. Parkinson's.
About a million.
It turned out there are far more people
with lymphedema then all those other
diseases combined.
How is it possible that we know so much
about all those other diseases and yet
this disease we know absolutely nothing
about including most people who haven't,
don't know that they actually have this
disease. So a lot of our effort has been,
is peeling back the onion of
what are all those obstacles? Uh,
well there are multitude.
Dr Roxanne mentioned one right off the
bat and that's the fact that if doctors
don't learn about this in medical tool,
they're not passing that information
on to their patients afterwards.
The fact that most of the people in the
United States who have lymphedema have
it as a result of cancer treatment.
They're being treated by oncologists
who very often their senses,
I've treated the cancer. Uh, if you
develop lymphedema, find a therapist,
don't complain,
I saved your life.
And unfortunately too many people have
taken that advice and gone ahead and done
that. We have the problem
of the word lymphedema.
It's a difficult word. People don't
remember it. We talk about TB,
Ms Als, how many people here can tell
me what als stands for? You can't.
The reason is you don't need to,
it's too complicated. If you had to,
it would put you at a distance
from knowing anything about
the disease. At learn,
we start using Ellie and we use it
pretty uniformly as as the [inaudible] an
acronym for it. For it. I was saying to,
we were talking earlier when it comes to,
what do you call it, I think
doctors, very often you,
you need to feel very much like God
considering that people are coming to you
looking to be cure.
So what happens when somebody comes to
you with something you don't know how to
treat and don't know how to cure?
Well, you have a couple of options.
Either you're or you're not god,
or perhaps this isn't that important.
I think there's a tendency
to lean toward the latter.
I think using words like condition
becomes a euphemism which softens the
importance of what this disease is.
And I was saying with Jess,
I talked about very strong headed woman
who runs a company with for compression.
She has a lymphedema as a result of breast
cancer and during our conversation I
said, well, you know, really when you have
a disease like 50 a month, blah, blah,
blah, and she stopped me and said, what
did you just say? I said, well, I said,
when you have a disease, like I don't
have a disease, I have a condition.
How dare you say I have a
disease? And I said, well,
you have a disease and the condition
is a euphemism. What disease?
Up in the dictionary there's a definition
for call doctor rocks and have a
conversation about it. I called Stan
just you know, to check and make sure.
Absolutely.
Her response after that was,
are you telling me I had the disease
of cancer and treating it gave me the
disease of lymph edema.
Now I'm twice as a raise.
I was before conditions.
You just have to live with
diseases you cure. I want a cure.
I thought,
well how fascinating.
Even language like that can be
a major factor in a movement.
The other thing is,
I met a couple of women when I
first took this job and I said,
what does it like to have lymphedema?
And the first response was, well,
build our worst things in the world.
And I said,
well then I just made a huge mistake and
I should be going doing those things,
which are more important rather
than doing this. And then they said,
do you want to know what it's really like?
And they began saying the things
that Kathy just said. Okay,
imagine you had 15 pounds of
weight on this part of your body.
You don't have the
other part of your body.
Your spouse never wants to
have sex with you again.
People mock you when
you're out on the street,
you end up in the hospital several times
a year with infection that you don't
know whether they're going to cure or not.
You love to travel,
but now you're afraid
to cause high altitudes,
exacerbate your lymphedema
and on and on and on.
And they finally get to the end of saying,
you know what?
Lymphedema is worse than cancer.
Cancer. The Cure. LYMPHEDEMA is forever.
The whole idea having a disease that
you have to treat for hours a day leaves
you to facilitate it for
the rest of your life.
And although we do say it in, in and
of itself, it doesn't lead to death.
I mean,
the fact is I get more memorials donated
to learn because of people who have had
infections that antibiotics
could no longer treat who
died as a result or people
who gained so much weight
because of their lymph edema,
that would be it debilitated
them and it caused, uh, uh,
other things to occur that actually lead
to a premature death. On the other hand,
though, there are lots of things we
don't deal with that we don't die from,
that impact our quality of life to such
an extent that we give a great deal of
attention to.
This hasn't been one and a big part of
our job right now is how do we develop
that activism so that people come forward.
I talked to dark Dr. Anthony Fowchee
down at the national institutes of health
and doctor [inaudible] was key during
the aids epidemic and he said he went to
Nih Beck in 1984.
And at that point he said Nih
was not very interested in aids.
It was effecting marginalized
populations. And uh, there was no, uh,
excitement about necessarily getting
overly involved in this. However,
because of groups like act up, gay
men's health crisis, et Cetera,
that came forward and said,
we are not taking no for an answer.
Shortly after NIH began
putting 10% of their budget,
$3 billion a year into aids research,
20 years later,
it was a treatable disease where
people could live normal lives.
Fast forward to us,
we got Senator Schumer to put in a $70
million appropriations requests for
lymphatic research.
The first seven calls,
I called up the office where people
saying it was a big step backwards.
We were wasting our time.
There would never be a cure for lymphedema
and we were wasting our time looking
for one.
I was shocked that the population of
people that have this disease had been so
cow by everything they've lived with up
to this point that they didn't even have
hope. We need people to have
hope. So with our organization,
we focus now not only on research but
certainly on education and advocacy.
Actually a two of the people here
from citizen group that rebranded our
organization, we used to be called
the lymphatic research foundation.
Now we're called lymphatic education
and research network and they helped
rebrand from citizen group to give us
the new name and expand our mission
because we need to do it all.
We need people to be angry.
We need people to be activists.
We have chapters all around the world at
this point and you'll see a little film
that a a Kathy hosts about
world and edema midday.
We created world lymph edema day and the
idea was we need more than awareness.
We need research,
we need it to be international and
we need to make this an international
priority.
So learned at this point has
a whole variety of programs
that not only feed into
researchers and doing research but also
for patients themselves to educate them
through a symposiums, asking
experts, et cetera. But uh,
also by allowing them to congregate and
feel that incredible embrace of another
person with a disease that they thought
they were the only one in the world had.
Cause it's only then that you get that
power that one needs to know I'm not
alone.
We are empowered.
We do have a right to aspire for more
and we're not going to stand still and be
quiet until we actually get
what we are searching for.
And that is we want new treatments and
cures and that's going to take money.
And we need government
to support us in that.
If we want to win this fight, we need
to stand together and educate the world.
All of us who've had the courage to
speak about our personal battles with
lymphedema or making a real difference
all across the u s even in Russia,
Australia and India are stories or giving
others hope as they realize they're
not alone.
I saw my day.
I support, but lymph, the magic
nice folder.
I support,
I support word
join working TV Monday.
I support,
I support
the name of the
please.
Okay,
I am Kyla from Nigeria and
I support the war amia.
Yay.